and so what got you guys do first and
then we'll bring on our other two
esteemed colleagues yes years ago so the
first one I think we have is Claude
speed from Grand Theft Auto 3 who is the
main character from GTA 3 doesn't speak
words the last character in Grand Theft
Auto history doesn't speak actually yeah
I city does and CJ and sideways does so
Claude is yeah he's like a leather coat
jacket wearing sort of like denim
trousers think he's from the east coast
I think he's from liberty city in New
York kind of thing that's the that's
what the lore says yeah yeah I'm so
you're at a disadvantage or maybe in an
advantage hey you don't know me man
let's go point oh that's good that's
good to go go yeah gopher oh I'm going
for sure Sam's Claude yeah cloudera
that's in their plot speed oh look the
cod alright so I just savor image it
yeah all right well I guess uh guys I'm
gonna have to grab my baseball bat so i
can go beat up some more hookers you
wanna come on over tonight gotta bother
jack my back pocket and got my trusty
Louisville Slugger and let's go find
some hookers again okay you kept shaking
essence of GTA 3 as well yeah just
assaulted you got a lot of work to do
yeah parallel free I don't like I mean
from immigrant from it from a serious
like auditioning standpoint yeah he he
looks young but he's also got that kind
of tough in this to him that little bit
of me like a New Yorker to him sort of a
strong a little bit of that Boston
accent all right boys get by me yeah we
got stuff to do tonight we got money to
make people to kill and we got some
business to take care of sue step in the
back of the car if I wanted to be
fooling around be like more of like it's
got a little scratch that face maybe he
said guys come on don't Joe Pesci a
Smith is here these pants are a little
tight on me I'm pissed off its friday
let's go steal some cars well you think
I'm funny yeah what's it about it that
sucks okay let's go let's go let go a
little bit in a different direction okay
I'm gonna go for second artist here and
sort of i think i think this individual
went to some sort of university i think
it was it what's the what's the really
good tech the science university that's
on these coasts like in my teen years
old yeah he's in MIT gradually okay
works in a secret government lab
somewhere in the west coast sorry yeah
he's fought he's shot a lot of soldiers
in the past he's shot la vallée and a
lot of crates lot crates he's cracked in
a lot of crates name's Gordon Freeman I
may have heard of him [ __ ] those crates
from heard of him not hurt him this if
you want I can be there you go in case
you need to like visualize it a little
bit okay and yes okay Matthew you wanna
go first this long then on a voice
gordon freeman i know it's boom no
pressure what's gordon freeman sir i I
for some reason I I seem having a little
bit of a higher palate yeah because he's
very you know he's he's tech-savvy he's
worked in the lab for some time um you
know but he's but he's definitely been
through the [ __ ] a little bit and had to
do some things he's not necessarily
proud of but whatever it requires to
make sure that those who can survive the
incident Black Mesa I managed to get
through okay get out of my look at that
look at he got that a little lip curl to
him yeah yeah yeah get behind me one of
the very few pictures of his face
actually yeah [ __ ] that's nice counting
over ending a crowbar to marisha see I
don't know for Gordon I kind of always
imagined like a little bit more of
almost like a william h macy kind of
thing going on I can see that ya know
he's got a little bit of that kind of
nasally thing going on but he's still
you know he still doesn't he still
sounds like he can take a punch every
once a while you know I'm gonna vote for
you on that these crabs me my son well
yeah congratulations on I was true
tremendous Gordon Freeman I got a couple
more for you too let's go for
PlayStation 1 not a lot launch game
first six months it was at the face of
the PlayStation you could say actually
we an animal that people aren't really
sure if it's a real animal I got lots of
tribal masks knows it crash bandicoot
yeah yeah yeah what is CrossFit because
they've never gay cuz like Sonic's the
one light with which like no matter what
voice they put on them people are like
oh that's already what's Alex I'm
waiting it'll forever scarred forever
scarred by Seville I'd get some chili
dog no no it's yeah Roger is a great job
yeah he unfortunately under the shadow
of his early sonic cartoons yes it's a
real tough one yeah so Christ bandicoots
in the same way where I don't think
people really think about crash talking
sure so I never thought of him talking
well he's kind of like you go first
first last time no you didn't i didn't
know you're right you're right you did
never mind you first I like I said he
doesn't really use words though yeah I
don't know gosh bring district has made
towser's thing back see that nobody's
got he's got the burgers yeah he's got
the fingerless gloves he's got the
sneakers on he's got the rolled up jeans
god I've never noticed he was fingerless
gloves before he's yeah yeah he's
everything in 90s you know mascot
character wanted to be you wanted to be
cool badass but also kind of chill and
hang you buddy cigarette look at me
hahaha you know if he was wearing a
shirt of Anna Papa wrote written on it
yeah it's like if we're talking like
crash bandicoot when it first came out
voice you know he's gonna be kind of
intense high energy a little zany but
you know wants to be chill with his
buddies drink ecto cooler you know
that's a little too young yeah I gonna
feel you know uh
I would want to punch him whoa sick
ollie you know that don't know when it's
is that that I would hate that when it
came out that's what it sounded like
yeah more days I like to think they make
him a little more serious yeah stoic
like I was gonna say almost a wily
coyote he's like hello and welcome to
care to crash bandicoot is a gex now
apparently yea crash aneurysm says the
and/or in the twit shot and now okay
let's swap it out yes let's do that soon
that's good thank you so much for
joining us today on the lobby
appreciative I where do people catch you
on Twitter and whatnot uh you can follow
me at marisha underscore rain down on
the score ah someone some [ __ ] ma
cherie so good I think that your name is
relatively unique enough that you could
have got away with it there's a
democratic politician named washer I
know there's no dining or dwyer yeah I'm
super lucky you are lucky you guys are
shown one time you'll binder and you
guys will find a parking lots of great
yeah guess we raining like Matrix
Revolutions to ask like really disappear
surely spider-man like just that type a
heavy heavy rain like that level of
intense right now you put medical number
in the raindrops uh yeah um marisha
underscore ray and of course you can
watch me on critical role and then I
actually have a new show just came out
on a geek and sundry called signal boost
yeah second exit went off just today
today yeah yeah yes look you for so on
it no I was your geek and sundry all the
time yeah sure what about yourself sir I
you can find me on Twitter as well under
at Matthew Mercer no one to score no
wonder score now sorry lucky bastard
yeah [ __ ] I stuff smack underscore
daddy 86 @ hotmail.com some jerk up
smack that Bell oh how dare he you know
Russia that's a tough one it's very few
porn sites exactly yeah I know that's it
registered no I god I still have it on
youjizz and I yeah I many other projects
of our from critical apartment we're all
just couple the game projects that are
coming up can't talk about yet great
announcements to come hot embargoes
indeed thank you so much already
appreciate it laura bailey and travis
willingham my mom marissa ray and
matching mercer they're popping off
don't worry
and you come how you doing good see you
against awake are you it's you how are
we talking Irish what top of the mornin
see it's great real I know I got a green
crowbar as well I can't get rid of yers
done yet you were we were watching from
the side yeah half life would totally
sound like Heisenberg oh yeah come on
true you do a gordon freeman you want
dude up according Freeman no I got
better ones I'll take the crowbar away
then actually before we get into those
what wonderful voice work have you lent
your guttural tones goodness oh my gosh
recently uh mr. second anime back in
like 2003 my first big role was a carnal
Roy Mustang and full metal alchemist was
one of my favs and then I've had roles
like guile and street fighter and Reggie
and infamous second son and Fred 104 in
halo 5 guardians which came out last
year wasn't mad max escape her scrotus
just a just a ton of really fun stuff I
didn't realize you were scrotus aki
that's a fantastic one yeah usually for
the giant horn coming out of his dick
yeah it's true giant horn crotch yeah it
was the best part of that is what they
didn't do that until they saw the
performance capture and no they
literally put a Styrofoam horn on my on
my crotch we have a picture of it really
yeah it really did you couldn't really
thought that they thought I was gonna
affect my my movement have these giant
exhaust pipes coming out of a shoulders
and they're like you know we should put
the horn on the wing yeah yeah somebody
did that and you got a picture of it oh
yeah wonderful famous right actually
yeah I can't not right now that that's
wonderful yeah Laura what about yourself
what have you worked on recently
recently recently halo 5 yeah as Olympia
veil uncharted 4 which is coming out
very soon Gears of War for which was
just announced I'm playing Kate in that
which is pretty exciting um street
fighter chunli world warcraft Jaina
Proudmoore you know what about Black
Widow and Avengers yeah no Magister
that's fantastic yeah but we have some
lesser-known characters maybe some of
these
don't really talk all that often which
maybe you guys can help us write the
auditions process we're doing for you
right now I definitely looked like
somebody who'll be able to pay you for
your voices I'll I sure hope so we are
expecting money I have you're joking
right all right great know any works for
me okay first one up we've got this is
going to be a little bit harder for you
Travis I think I'm sorry ah from the
video game portal and also video game
portal 2 yes it's chelle I like Joe the
lady who doesn't speak at all much later
I'm city 17 where is she I mean I'm
gonna look at her I know what she looks
like but I was there she is look at her
I have popular cosplay as well yes I
actually have arisen pieces of it you do
the boots I know the boots experts I
know what's up I have you done Aggie
what do you think chelwood sound like
you know what's weird as I see her with
like an accent mmm like a British accent
but um British accent English accent um
but then she's kind of something Laura
Laura Croft and I don't know if that's I
like the like the idea of her at the
beginning sounding a little more
flustered and then by the end just being
like oh whatever like over everything
other one yeah yeah I think that's good
Oh a biker look a bit more i'll be
stopping push you down yeah look I've
got me portal garden okay I'm jumping
for big to be look out the cake is alone
no I tell you yeah i think i got it i'm
just saying i don't know that's great
your your yeah one audition 1 london
feels 1v shrew damn I oliver twist or
something yeah I'm like the lost child
and Mary poppy him yeah bit part name is
or something oh please revolution let's
go and next one up very difficult
character been in dozens and dozens of
games doesn't speak at all doesn't even
have the game named a pacman consider
he's the main character its length yeah
this is a competition you'd be killing
it you've already picked up I'm based on
my terrible descriptions fair play thank
you thank you yeah I go first listen
yeah go for it yawning link just kind of
like from the South you know look at me
look at you got a little sprite ears and
fingerless gloves
fern green you know Green is the state
color of Missouri and that's not
actually true but it is my world I'm
coming for you was until de the iris guy
wasn't gonna fact-check that there's one
yeah free the Privy well the only boys
I've donner kid trunks and shin chan so
I'm gonna say sounds kinda like this and
he's off to save the princess tastic yep
I can just see the sales for Zelda
spiking even hired man yeah I mean one
can not buy that right hoop uh next one
off I don't know why I put this one in
and I think we'd make it a mission to
not do anything serious yeah that's good
i like it i'm ready to shoot i already
took I already took gel too seriously
I'm gonna I gotta fix it and mix it up
is a anthropomorphised piece of flesh
which jumps around a platform or at very
high speeds this is super meat boy on
the video game super cool doesn't speak
at all he loves bandage girl that's all
seem so cute and he's made of me that's
all he doesn't actually speak he just
makes for dolphin noises look up antenna
kinda like a dolphin to me that's just
that's discussing is up the sound of him
talking or just his meat like flopping
it's him laughing oh I like it guess
what this sound is in farting guessed it
I just have that ability to your home
and right I'll just need burping and
we've got everything you wow you just
call those things that's why I'm an
amazing street so yeah you cover the
fire chica yeah that was like a one on a
scale of one to ten when she likes her
off I think that's actually really
perfect for him to only communicate and
burps and farts yeah yeah perfect
beautiful audition nailed on and dusted
and the last one we have here have a
character a female character although
many people did not realize she was
female character until the end of the
video game Mario Brothers you are you
brother slim yeah Luigi got the big
twist we're waiting for after 20
nada me [ __ ] great oh my gosh like
takes off the Hat and a bunch of I'm
saying I want to eegees like add me to
your princess is another connection our
losses ah no it's not it's Thomas are
from metroid oh oh although she's
wearing zero suit there I think yo you
can definitely see she's yeah it's
definitely a lady it's a very lady face
yeah and her Lane George yes she looks
like dinner ladies listen lady like me
mm my god Laura you're up first I think
she'd be kind of soft spoken actually
tough but calm yeah I like it I can't
even make fun of it looks like a laser
sword I like the bodysuit you can do the
voice of the laser sword if you want
yeah eNOS or the best laser sword around
pretty good he's my sidekick laser sword
there you go you coulda yeah it's like a
buddy comet the new zelda is gonna be
buddy between Zelda that's right it's
just going yeah sorry about sore
you